are you ready for this I'm ready I can't
always say that but now I'm like bring
it on okay seven years later I got this
this is like living on a whole nother
level fabulous the Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills hurt back for Season seven
eg caught up with the cast at their
premiere party and nowhere else Beverly
Hills lavish over-the-top dramatic we
brought back the fun this year it was
not fun last year down nerve not to
judge it but this year we have more fun
not really are you beating up this year
no they gave a TA wrong who's a fun
season kind of a mixed bag of a lot of
different things so I guess there's
always but you know it's all always a
little rubber for some people that his
brother criticized that you don't know
what I deal with every night I mean
listen it's not without its ups and
downs when there's a new year there's
some fresh blood yes even Sassoon and
doreet kenzley have joined the cast and
will seemingly bring the drama one word
to describe Dori
I should save that for the reunion
overall it was really enjoyable to meet
these women I think some more than
others I don't like most to eat and
that's what I think you are we are a
moment I think maybe that's more Dorito
show than my issue Americans need to
kind of take a deep breath you're an
American you're born in Connecticut my
question is what accent do we have today
right now if you're a lady you've got no
undies on you've got a short dress
cross your legs your accent is a hot
topic I didn't realize it really until I
started this to be honest with you I
love the access valve we are at the
moment but I actually think she's a
fantastic addition you have to wait and
see I want you to be the judge the
audience estimate the judges and I was
protective of the newbie who's a lovely
girl but sometimes you might approach a
bit wrong but I think that's what we
need to see on television we need to see
people with opinions to meet people that
sit on the fence I'm not interest in
people like well I see both sides no
Vanderpump likes to call me Switzerland
seeing Lisa Vanderpump always stirring
something up
[Music]